That was a whirlwind tour of Kubernetes.
Like Docker, Kubernetes makes
it really easy to run and
introspect our applications.
That's what I call automation.
This lesson shows you many of
the deployment primitives Kubernetes
offers Dev's.
At this point, you should be able to
see the power of Kubernetes" higher
level abstractions which allow you
to focus on your application more so
than managing an employment.
But what if I told you these
were just the basics and
the next lesson we're going to
take off the training wheels and
learn to not only scale your
application automatically.
But how to perform rolling
updates without downtime.
How to work with sensitive
information and so much more.
See you in the next lesson.